The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN GUTTAG: We ended
the last lecture
looking at greedy algorithms.
Today I want to discuss the
pros and cons of greedy.
Oh, I should mention--
in response to popular demand,
I have put the PowerPoint up,
so if you download the ZIP
file, you'll find the questions,
including question 1, the
first question, plus the code,
plus the PowerPoint.
We actually do read Piazza,
and sometimes, at least,
pay attention.
We should pay
attention all the time.
So what are the pros
and cons of greedy?
The pro-- and it's
a big pro-- is
that it's really easy to
implement, as you could see.
Also enormously important--
it's really fast.
We looked at the
complexity last time--
it was m log n-- quite quick.
The downside-- and this can
be either a big problem or not
a big problem--
is that it doesn't
actually solve
the problem, in the sense
that we've asked ourselves
to optimize something.
And we get a solution that
may or may not be optimal.
Worse-- we don't even
know, in this case,
how close to optimal it is.
Maybe it's almost optimal, but
maybe it's really far away.
And that's a big problem
with many greedy algorithms.
There are some very
sophisticated greedy algorithms
we won't be looking at that
give you a bound on how good
the approximation is, but
most of them don't do that.
Last time we looked
at an alternative
to a greedy algorithm
that was guaranteed
to find the right solution.
It was a brute force algorithm.
The basic idea is simple--
that you enumerate all
possible combinations of items,
remove the combination
whose total units exceed
the allowable weight, and
then choose the winner
from those that are remaining.
Now let's talk about
how to implement it.
And the way I want to
implement it is using something
called a search tree.
There are lots of different
ways to implement it.
In the second half
of today's lecture,
you'll see why I
happen to choose
this particular approach.
So what is a search tree?
A tree is, basically,
a kind of graph.
And we'll hear much more
about graphs next week.
But this is a simple form
where you have a root
and then children of the root.
In this particular
form, research C,
you have two children.
So we start with the root.
And then we look at
our list of elements
to be considered
that we might take,
and we look at the first
element in that list.
And then we draw a
left branch, which
shows the consequence of
choosing to take that element,
and a right branch, which
shows the consequences of not
taking that element.
And then we consider
the second element,
and so on and so forth, until we
get to the bottom of the tree.
So by convention, the left
element will mean we took it,
the right direction will
mean we didn't take it.
And then we apply it recursively
to the non-leaf children.
The leaf means we
get to the end,
we've considered the last
element to be considered.
Nothing else to think about.
When we get to the
code, we'll see
that, in addition to the
description being recursive,
it's convenient to write
the code that way, too.
And then finally,
we'll choose the node
that has the highest value
that meets our constraints.
So let's look at an example.
My example is I have
my backpack that
can hold a certain number
of calories if you will.
And I'm choosing between, to
keep it small, a beer, a pizza,
and a burger--
three essential food groups.
The first thing I explore on
the left is take the beer,
and then I have the
pizza and the burger
to continue to consider.
I then say, all right,
let's take the pizza.
Now I have just the burger.
Now I taste the burger.
This traversal of this
generation of the tree
is called left-most depth-most.
So I go all the way down
to the bottom of the tree.
I then back up a
level and say, all
right, I'm now at the bottom.
Let's go back and
see what happens
if I make the other choice
at the one level up the tree.
So I went up and
said, well, now let's
see what happens if I
make a different decision,
as in we didn't take the burger.
And then I work my way--
this is called backtracking--
up another level.
I now say, suppose, I didn't
take the piece of pizza.
Now I have the beer
only and only the burger
to think about, so
on and so forth,
until I've generated
the whole tree.
You'll notice it will always be
the case that the leftmost leaf
of this tree has got all
the possible items in it,
and the rightmost leaf none.
And then I just check
which of these leaves
meets the constraint
and what are the values.
And if I compute the value
and the calories in each one,
and if our constraint
was 750 calories,
then I get to choose
the winner, which is--
I guess, it's the
pizza and the burger.
Is that right?
The most value under 750.
That's the way I go through.
It's quite a
straightforward algorithm.
And I don't know why we draw our
trees with the root at the top
and the leaves at the bottom.
My only conjecture is
computer scientists
don't spend enough
time outdoors.
Now let's think of the
computational complexity
of this process.
The time is going to be based
on the total number of nodes
we generate.
So if we know the number of
nodes that are in the tree,
we then know the complexity
of the algorithm,
the asymptotic complexity.
Well, how many levels
do we have in the tree?
Just the number of items, right?
Because at each
level of the tree
we're deciding to take
or not to take an item.
And so we can only do that for
the number of items we have.
So if we go back, for example,
and we look at the tree--
not that tree, that tree--
and we count the
number of levels,
it's going to be based upon
the total number of items.
We know that because if you
look at, say, the leftmost node
at the bottom, we've made
three separate decisions.
So counting the
root, it's n plus 1.
But we don't care
about plus 1 when we're
doing asymptotic complexity.
So that tells us how many
levels we have in the tree.
The next question we
need to ask is, how many
nodes are there at each level?
And you can look at this
and see-- the deeper we go,
the more nodes we
have at each level.
In fact, if we come
here, we can see
that the number of
nodes at level i--
depth i of the
tree-- is 2 to the i.
That makes sense if you
remember last time we
looked at binary numbers.
We're saying we're representing
our choices as either 0
or 1 for what we take.
If we have n items
to choose from,
then the number of
possible choices
is 2 to the n, the
size of the powerset.
So that will tell us the
number of nodes at each level.
So if there are n items, the
number of nodes in the tree
is going to be the sum
from 0 to n of 2 to the i
because we have
that many levels.
And if you've studied
a little math,
you know that's exactly
2 to the n plus 1.
Or if you do what I do,
you look it up in Wikipedia
and you know it's
2 to the n plus 1.
Now, there's an
obvious optimization.
We don't need to
explore the whole tree.
If we get to a point where
the backpack is overstuffed,
there's no point in saying,
should we take this next item?
Because we know we can't.
I generated a bunch
of leaves that
were useless because
the weight was too high.
So you could always
abort early and say, oh,
no point in generating the
rest of this part of the tree
because we know everything
in it will be too heavy.
Adding something cannot
reduce the weight.
It's a nice optimization.
It's one you'll see we
actually do in the code.
But it really doesn't
change the complexity.
It's not going to change
the worst-cost complexity.
Exponential, as we saw this,
I think, in Eric's lecture,
is a big number.
You don't usually
like 2 to the n.
Does this mean that brute
force is never useful?
Well, let's give it a try.
We'll look at some code.
Here is the implementation.
So it's maxVal,
toConsider, and avail.
And then we say, if toConsider
is empty or avail is 0--
avail is an index, we're going
to go through the list using
that to tell us
whether or not we still
have an element to consider--
then the result will be the
tuple 0 and the empty tuple.
We couldn't take anything.
This is the base
of our recursion.
Either there's nothing
left to consider or there's
no available weight--
the Val, as the
amount of weight,
is 0 or toConsider is empty.
Well, if either
of those are true,
then we ask whether
to consider * 0,
the first element to look at.
Is that cost greater
than availability?
If it is, we don't need to
explore the left branch.
because it means we can't
afford to put that thing
in the backpack, the knapsack.
There's just no room for it.
So we'll explore the
right branch only.
The result will be whatever the
maximum value is of toConsider
of the remainder of the list--
the list with the first element
sliced off--
and availability unchanged.
So it's a recursive
implementation, saying,
now we only have to consider
the right branch of the tree
because we knew we
couldn't take this element.
It just weighs too
much, or costs too much,
or was too fattening,
in my case.
Otherwise, we now have to
consider both branches.
So we'll set next item to
toConsider of 0, the first one,
and explore the left branch.
On this branch, there
are two possibilities
to think about, which I'm
calling withVal and withToTake.
So I'm going to call maxVal
of toConsider of everything
except the current element and
pass in an available weight
of avail minus whatever--
well, let me widen this so
we can see the whole code.
This is not going to let me
widen this window any more.
Shame on it.
Let me see if I can
get rid of the console.
Well, we'll have
to do this instead.
So we're going to call
maxVal with everything
except the current
element and give it
avail minus the cost of that
next item of toConsider sub 0.
Because we know that the
availability, available weight
has to have that cost
subtracted from it.
And then we'll add to withVal
next item dot getValue.
So that's a value
if we do take it.
Then we'll explore the
right branch-- what
happens if we don't take it?
And then we'll choose
the better branch.
So it's a pretty simple
recursive algorithm.
We just go all the
way to the bottom
and make the right
choice at the bottom,
and then percolate back up, like
so many recursive algorithms.
We have a simple
program to test it.
I better start a console
now if I'm going to run it.
And we'll testGreedys on foods.
Well, we'll testGreedys
and then we'll testMaxVal.
So I'm building
the same thing we
did in Monday's
lecture, the same menu.
And I'll run the
same testGreedys
we looked at last time.
And we'll see whether or not
we get something better when
we run the truly optimal one.
Well, indeed we do.
You remember that last
time and, fortunately,
this time too, the best
we did was a value of 318.
But now we see we can
actually get to 353 if we use
the truly optimal algorithm.
So we see it ran pretty
quickly and actually
gave us a better answer than we
got from the greedy algorithm.
And it's often the case.
If I have time at the
end, I'll show you
an optimization
program you might
want to run that works
perfectly fine to use
this kind of brute
force algorithm on.
Let's go back to the PowerPoint.
So I'm just going through
the code again we just ran.
This was the header we saw--
toConsider, as the
items that correspond
to nodes higher up the
tree, and avail, as I said,
the amount of space.
And again, here's what
the body of the code
loooked like, I took
out the comments.
One of the things you might
think about in your head
when you look at this code is
putting the comments back in.
I always find that for
me a really good way
to understand code that I didn't
write is to try and comment it.
And that helps me sort of
force myself to think about
what is it really doing.
So you'll have both versions--
you'll have the PowerPoint
version without the
comments and the actual code
with the comments.
You can think about
looking at this
and then looking
at the real code
and making sure that
you're understanding jibes.
I should point out that
this doesn't actually
build the search tree.
We've got this local variable
result, starting here,
that records the best
solution found so far.
So it's not the picture I drew
where I generate all the nodes
and then I inspect them.
I just keep track--
as I generate a node, I
say, how good is this?
Is it better than the
best I've found so far?
If so, it becomes the new best.
And I can do that because
every node I generate
is, in some sense, a legal
solution to the problem.
Probably rarely is it the
final optimal solution
but it's at least
a legal solution.
And so if it's
better than something
we saw before, we can
make it the new best.
This is very common.
And this is, in fact, what
most people do with it
when they use a search tree--
they don't actually
build the tree
in the pictorial way
we've looked at it
but play some trick like
this of just keeping
track of their results.
Any questions about this?
All right.
We did just try it on
example from lecture 1.
And we saw that it worked great.
It gave us a better answer.
It finished quickly.
But we should not take too
much solace from the fact
that it finished quickly
because 2 to the eighth
is actually a
pretty tiny number.
Almost any algorithm is fine
when I'm working on something
this small.
Let's look now at what happens
if we have a bigger menu.
Here is some code
to do a bigger menu.
Since, as you will discover
if you haven't already,
I'm a pretty lazy
person, I didn't
want to write out a menu with
a 100 items or even 50 items.
So I wrote some code
to generate the menus.
And I used randomness
to do that.
This is a Python
library we'll be
using a lot for the
rest of the semester.
It's used any time you want
to generate things at random
and do many other things.
We'll come back to it a lot.
Here we're just going to
use a very small part of it.
To build a large menu
of some numItems--
and we're going to
give the maximum value
and the maximum
cost for each item.
We'll assume the minimum
is, in this case, 1.
Items will start empty.
And then for i in
range number of items,
I'm going to call this function
random dot randint that
takes a range of integers from
1 to, actually in this case,
maxVal minus 1, or 1 to
maxVal, actually, in this case.
And it just chooses
one of them at random.
So when you run this, you don't
know what it's going to get.
Random dot randint might
return 1, it might return 23,
it might return 54.
The only thing you know
is it will be an integer.
And then I'm going to build
menus ranging from 5 items
to 60 items--
buildLargeMenu, the number
of items, with maxVal of 90
and a maxCost of 250,
pleasure and calories.
And then I'm going to test
maxVal on each of these menus.
So building menus of
various sizes at random
and then just trying to find the
optimal value for each of them.
Let's look at the code.
Let's comment this out, we
don't need to run that again.
So we'll build a
large menu and then
we'll try it for a bunch of
items and see what we get.
So it's going along.
Trying the menu up to
30 went pretty quickly.
So even 2 to the 30
didn't take too long.
But you might notice it's kind
of bogging down, we got 35.
I guess, I could ask
the question now--
it was one of the questions
I was going to ask as a poll
but maybe I won't bother--
how much patience do we have?
When do you think we'll run
out of patience and quit?
If you're out of
patience, raise your hand.
Well, some of you are way
more patient than I am.
So we're going to quit anyway.
We were trying to do 40.
It might have finished 40, 45.
I've never waited long
enough to get to 45.
It just is too long.
That raises the
question, is it hopeless?
And in theory, yes.
As I mentioned last time, it
is an inherently exponential
problem.
The answer is-- in practice, no.
Because there's something
called dynamic programming,
which was invented by a
fellow at the RAND Corporation
called Richard Bellman,
a rather remarkable
mathematician/computer
scientist.
He wrote a whole book
on it, but I'm not sure
why because it's not
that complicated.
When we talk about
dynamic programming,
it's a kind of a funny
story, at least to me.
I learned it and I
didn't know anything
about the history of it.
And I've had all sorts
of theories about why it
was called dynamic programming.
You know how it is, how people
try and fit a theory to data.
And then I read a
history book about it,
and this was Bellman's
own description
of why he called it
dynamic programming.
And it turned out,
as you can see,
he basically chose a word
because it was the description
that didn't mean anything.
Because he was doing
mathematics, and at the time
he was being funded by a part
of the Defense Department
that didn't approve
of mathematics.
And he wanted to
conceal that fact.
And indeed at the time, the
head of Defense Appropriations
in the US Congress didn't
much like mathematics.
And he was afraid
that he didn't want
to have to go and testify and
tell people he was doing math.
So he just invented
something that no one
would know what it meant.
And years of students
spent time later trying
to figure out what
it actually did mean.
Anyway, what's the basic idea?
To understand it I want
to temporarily abandon
the knapsack problem and look
at a much simpler problem--
Fibonacci numbers.
You've seen this already, with
cute little bunnies, I think,
when you saw it.
N equals 0, n
equals 1-- return 1.
Otherwise, fib of n minus
1 plus fib of n minus 2.
And as I think you saw
when you first saw it,
it takes a long time to run.
Fib of 120, for example,
is a very big number.
It's shocking how
quickly Fibonacci grows.
So let's think about
implementing it.
If we run Fibonacci--
well, maybe we'll just do that.
So here is fib of n,
let's just try running it.
And again, we'll test
people's patience.
We'll see how long
we're letting it run.
I'm going to try for
i in the range of 121.
We'll print fib of i.
Comes clumping along.
It slows down pretty quickly.
And if you look at it,
it's kind of surprising
it's this slow because these
numbers aren't that big.
These are not enormous numbers.
Fib of 35 is not a huge number.
Yet it took a long
time to compute.
So you have the numbers
growing pretty quickly
but the computation, actually,
seems to be growing faster
than the results.
We're at 37.
It's going to gets slower and
slower, even though our numbers
are not that big.
The question is,
what's going on?
Why is it taking so
long for Fibonacci
to compute these results?
Well, let's call it and
look at the question.
And to do that I want to
look at the call tree.
This is for Fibonacci
of 6, which is only 13,
which, I think, most
of us would agree
was not a very big number.
And let's look
what's going on here.
If you look at this,
what in some sense
seems really stupid about it?
What is it doing that a
rational person would not want
to do if they could avoid it?
It's bad enough to
do something once.
But to do the same thing
over and over again
is really wasteful.
And if we look at this,
we'll see, for example,
that fib 4 is being
computed here,
and fib 4 is being
computed here.
Fib 3 is being considered
here, and here, and here.
And do you think we'll get
a different answer for fib 3
in one place when we get
it in the other place?
You sure hope not.
So you think, well, what
should we do about this?
How would we go about avoiding
doing the same work over
and over again?
And there's kind of
an obvious answer,
and that answer is at the
heart of dynamic programming.
What's the answer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN GUTTAG: Exactly.
And I'm really happy that
someone in the front row
answered the question because
I can throw it that far.
You store the answer and then
look it up when you need it.
Because we know that we can
look things up very quickly.
Dictionary, despite what
Eric said in his lecture,
almost all the time
works in constant time
if you make it big enough,
and it usually is in Python.
We'll see later in the
term how to do that trick.
So you store it and then you'd
never have to compute it again.
And that's the basic trick
behind dynamic programming.
And it's something
called memoization,
as in you create a memo and
you store it in the memo.
So we see this here.
Notice that what we're doing
is trading time for space.
It takes some space to store
the old results, but negligible
related to the time we save.
So here's the trick.
We're going to create a table
to record what we've done.
And then before
computing fib of x,
we'll check if the value
has already been computed.
If so, we just look
it up and return it.
Otherwise, we'll compute it--
it's the first time-- and
store it in the table.
Here is a fast implementation
of Fibonacci that does that.
It looks like the
old one, except it's
got an extra argument--
memo-- which is a dictionary.
The first time we call it,
the memo will be empty.
It tries to return
the value in the memo.
If it's not there, an exception
will get raised, we know that.
And it will branch to
here, compute the result,
and then store it in
the memo and return it.
It's the same old
recursive thing
we did before but with the memo.
Notice, by the way, that
I'm using exceptions
not as an error
handling mechanism,
really, but just as
a flow of control.
To me, this is cleaner than
writing code that says,
if this is in the keys, then
do this, otherwise, do that.
It's slightly fewer lines of
code, and for me, at least,
easier to read to use try-except
for this sort of thing.
Let's see what happens
if we run this one.
Get rid of the slow fib
and we'll run fastFib.
Wow.
We're already done with fib 120.
Pretty amazing, considering last
time we got stuck around 40.
It really works, this
memoization trick.
An enormous difference.
When can you use it?
It's not that memorization
is a magic bullet that
will solve all problems.
The problems it can solve,
it can help with, really,
is the right thing.
And by the way, as we'll see, it
finds an optimal solution, not
an approximation.
Problems have two things
called optimal substructure,
overlapping subproblems.
What are these mean?
We have optimal
substructure when
a globally optimal
solution can be
found by combining optimal
solutions to local subproblems.
So for example, when
x is greater than 1
we can solve fib x by solving
fib x minus 1 and fib x minus 2
and adding those
two things together.
So there is optimal
substructure--
you solve these two smaller
problems independently
of each other and then combine
the solutions in a fast way.
You also have to have something
called overlapping subproblems.
This is why the memo worked.
Finding an optimal
solution has to involve
solving the same
problem multiple times.
Even if you have
optimal substructure,
if you don't see the same
problem more than once--
creating a memo.
Well, it'll work, you can
still create the memo.
You'll just never
find anything in it
when you look things
up because you're
solving each problem once.
So you have to be solving the
same problem multiple times
and you have to be able to
solve it by combining solutions
to smaller problems.
Now, we've seen things with
optimal substructure before.
In some sense, merge
sort worked that way--
we were combining
separate problems.
Did merge sort have
overlapping subproblems?
No, because-- well,
I guess, it might
have if the list had the same
element many, many times.
But we would expect, mostly not.
Because each time we're
solving a different problem,
because we have different
lists that we're now
sorting and merging.
So it has half of it
but not the other.
Dynamic programming will
not help us for sorting,
cannot be used to
improve merge sort.
Oh, well, nothing
is a silver bullet.
What about the knapsack problem?
Does it have these
two properties?
We can look at it in
terms of these pictures.
And it's pretty clear that it
does have optimal substructure
because we're taking the left
branch and the right branch
and choosing the winner.
But what about
overlapping subproblems?
Are we ever solving, in this
case, the same problem--
add two nodes?
Well, do any of these
nodes look identical?
In this case, no.
We could write a dynamic
programming solution
to the knapsack problem--
and we will-- and run
it on this example,
and we'd get the right answer.
We would get zero speedup.
Because at each
node, if you can see,
the problems are different.
We have different things in the
knapsack or different things
to consider.
Never do we have the same
contents and the same things
left to decide.
So "maybe" was not a bad
answer if that was the answer
you gave to this question.
But let's look at
a different menu.
This menu happens to
have two beers in it.
Now, if we look at
what happens, do
we see two nodes that are
solving the same problem?
The answer is what?
Yes or no?
I haven't drawn the
whole tree here.
Well, you'll notice
the answer is yes.
This node and this node are
solving the same problem.
Why is it?
Well, in this node,
we took this beer
and still had this
one to consider.
But in this node,
we took that beer
but it doesn't matter
which beer we took.
We still have a beer in
the knapsack and a burger
and a slice to consider.
So we got there different ways,
by choosing different beers,
but we're in the same place.
So in fact, we
actually, in this case,
do have the same problem
to solve more than once.
Now, here I had two
things that were the same.
That's not really necessary.
Here's another
very small example.
And the point I want to
make here is shown by this.
So here I have again
drawn a search tree.
And I'm showing you this
because, in fact, it's exactly
this tree that will be producing
in our dynamic programming
solution to the
knapsack problem.
Each node in the tree starts
with what you've taken--
initially, nothing,
the empty set.
What's left, the total value,
and the remaining calories.
There's some redundancy
here, by the way.
If I know what I've taken, I
could already always compute
the value and what's left.
But this is just so
it's easier to see.
And I've numbered the
nodes here in the order
in which they're get generated.
Now, the thing that
I want you to notice
is, when we ask whether we're
solving the same problem,
we don't actually
care what we've taken.
We don't even care
about the value.
All we care is, how much room
we have left in the knapsack
and which items we
have left to consider.
Because what I take next or
what I take remaining really
has nothing to do with how
much value I already have
because I'm trying to maximize
the value that's left,
independent of
previous things done.
Similarly, I don't care why
I have a 100 calories left.
Whether I used it up on beers
or a burger, doesn't matter.
All that matters is that
I just have 100 left.
So we see in a large complicated
problem it could easily
be a situation where different
choices of what to take
and what to not take would
leave you in a situation
where you have the same
number of remaining calories.
And therefore you are solving a
problem you've already solved.
At each node, we're just
given the remaining weight,
maximize the value by choosing
among the remaining items.
That's all that matters.
And so indeed, you will have
overlapping subproblems.
As we see in this tree, for
the example we just saw,
the box is around a place
where we're actually
solving the same problem,
even though we've
made different decisions about
what to take, A versus B.
And in fact, we have
different amounts of value
in the knapsack--
6 versus 7.
What matters is we still
have C and D to consider
and we have two units left.
It's a small and easy step.
I'm not going to walk
you through the code
because it's kind
of boring to do so.
How do you modify the maxVal we
looked at before to use a memo?
First, you have to add the third
argument, which is initially
going to be set to
the empty dictionary.
The key of the memo
will be a tuple--
the items left to be considered
and the available weight.
Because the items left to
be considered are in a list,
we can represent the items
left to be considered
by how long the list is.
Because we'll start at
the front item and just
work our way to the end.
And then the function
works, essentially,
exactly the same
way fastFib worked.
I'm not going to run it for
you because we're running out
of time.
You might want to
run it yourself
because it is kind of fun to
see how really fast it is.
But more interestingly,
we can look at this table.
This column is what we would
get with the original recursive
implementation where
we didn't use a memo.
And it was therefore 2
to the length of items.
And as you can see,
it gets really big
or, as we say at the end, huge.
But the number of
calls grows incredibly
slowly for the dynamic
programming solution.
In the beginning
it's worth Oh, well.
But by the time we get to
the last number I wrote,
we're looking at 43,000
versus some really big number
I don't know how to pronounce--
18 somethings.
Incredible improvement
in performance.
And then at the
end, it's a number
we couldn't fit on the
slide, even in tiny font.
And yet, only 703,000 calls.
How can this be?
We know the problem is
inherently exponential.
Have we overturned the
laws of the universe?
Is dynamic programming a
miracle in the liturgical sense?
No.
But the thing I want
you to carry away
is that computational complexity
can be a very subtle notion.
The running time
of fastMaxVal is
governed by the number
of distinct pairs
that we might be able to
use as keys in the memo--
toConsider and available.
The number of possible values
of toConsider is small.
It's bounded by the
length of the items.
If I have a 100 items,
it's 0, 1, 2, up to a 100.
The possible values
of available weight
is harder to characterize.
But it's bounded by the number
of distinct sums of weights
you can get.
If I start with
750 calories left,
what are the possibilities?
Well, in fact, in this case,
maybe we can take only 750
because we're using with units.
So it's small.
But it's actually smaller
than that because it
has to do with the
combinations of ways
I can add up the units I have.
I know this is complicated.
It's not worth my going through
the details in the lectures.
It's covered in considerable
detail in the assigned reading.
Quickly summarizing
lectures 1 and 2,
here's what I want
you to take away.
Many problems of
practical importance
can be formulated as
optimization problems.
Greedy algorithms often provide
an adequate though often not
optimal solution.
Even though finding
an optimal solution
is, in theory,
exponentially hard,
dynamic programming really
often yields great results.
It always gives you a correct
result and it's sometimes,
in fact, most of the times
gives it to you very quickly.
Finally, in the
PowerPoint, you'll
find an interesting
optimization problem
having to do with whether or
not you should roll over problem
that grades into a quiz.
And it's simply a question
of solving this optimization
problem.